free will is an illusion humans are
nothing with moist robots
and let it happen all right maestro bots
I think that's a great phrase that's
what we are we're moist robots
that's what cognitive science that's
what naturalism says now this is the
this is the conclusion that is out there
as Tom Wolfe says in in in the zeitgeist
this is what people think follows from
cognitive science and from a
materialistic view of the mind and I
think it's very important that it
doesn't follow it just does not follow
and that in fact scientists who think it
follows are committing a very simple
sort of freshman mistake they are
confusing the ideology of the manifest
image with the manifest image the fact
Chiron thinks there's colors so why but
if we let the manifest if we let the
ideology of the manifest image define
the word color then we have - oh well
then there's no color so if that's what
you mean by color colors don't exist if
that's what you mean by consciousness
consciousness doesn't exist if that's
what you mean
but we don't say that we say well you
know the the ideology of the manifest
image is not accurate people have been
making mistakes don't take it at its
face value and look at what the manifest
image actually is and you see that there
is there are varieties of free will that
people recognize and deal with every day
they make the stations on the basis of
it these are robust concepts of free
will that have zero to do with
determinism and are perfectly consistent
with determinism they're compatible so
that you can be a compatible list in
good conscience what you have to give up
is the idea that the ideology of the
manifest image rules as far as defining
the terms because it doesn't there's a
perfectly legitimate concept of free
will which is a somewhat political
concept
there we have for the for the law we
have to draw boundaries but we don't
make the mistake of thinking that these
are we're harming nature at the joints
there's no joint there in nature you can
16 you can drive a car 15 and a half you
can't yeah that's what you're right I'm
saying that the free will is quite
properly seen as falling right out of
political facts which are available in
the manifest image none of us want to
live without it if you go around saying
free will doesn't exist free will is an
illusion you're actually undercutting
the very glue civilization and that's
the reason that people should be upset
about it if you don't believe that you
should learn about the experiments that
have been done I think that's Wilson
schoolers the most striking we're
undergraduates at Santa Barbara really
one of two passages from transcripts
book the astonishing hypothesis one says
why I'm so sold we don't have free will
you you know every decision you make is
already determined by your brain the
other one same length from the same book
but the head says nothing about freewill
then the students are given an
opportunity to make money on it by
solving a puzzle and it's pointed out to
them that in fact there's a way to cheat
please don't cheat be honest
which group cheats the one that we're
just told by Francis Crick Nobel
laureate that they don't have people
they eat much more and this is not an
isolated result there are a lot of these
and it's not so surprising if you if
science authoritative Lee tells people
they don't have free will
people tend to believe that and since
they tend to believe that
then don't think very hard about whether
they really ought to do things they
think you know I'm sort of off the hook
you know I'm a moist robot just sit back
and enjoy life and so people's behavior
degenerates into antisocial behavior
what you're saying reminds to build some
of it
if people believe accepted evolution I'm
gonna ask like act like B that's what
creationists tell people the fact is
they don't act like these people that
accept evolution are just as well as
other people so I mean you'reyou're
posing a danger which I demonstrate is
which I'm in which I claim is only
empirically demonstrated in this
questionnaire thing
you